every immigration argument that you hear
then they never come from a yeah well
how does it affect you personally well
you know these immigrants they come to
our country
they burden our taxes and what they do
is they come here and they get in our
education system in our health care not
gonna pay the tax my taxes have to pay
that well what the [ __ ] are you doing to
me every time you have a kid every time
you have a kid cuz its American I should
pull up a chaise lounge and wave a flag
while fifteen of those things come out
of you hey everyone I can't wait to pay
for these they're American
I have a mastectomy and an abortion on
my record but I can't wait for all your
[ __ ] fat in it miss Midwestern cancer
come out here what are you Catholic
come on multiply love it love it
I'll get a second job okay well these
immigrants you know they don't speak the
language then don't talk to him I solve
your problem that was quick you know who
speaks the language perfectly your
next-door neighbor you've lived at eight
and a half years you've never said one
[ __ ] word to that guy you avert eye
contact should you check the mail at the
same time
so why would you give a [ __ ] with the
guy selling kamyp knobs in a cart in the
park speech it's not a [ __ ] business
and all is all the cliched arguments
like that whether they're lazy that have
shipped this and they're criminals and
all this they all those arguments go
against the main cliched argument of
their taking American jobs I live on the
Mexican border I lived seven miles off
the Mexican border in a town Bisbee
Arizona little town I can go out any day
and watch Border Patrol arresting these
guys by the Dozen eleven at a time out
of a Dodge Omni like a clown car with
plastic cuffs and you're right they
don't speak the language and they
probably have no education they don't
have [ __ ] shoes at the time like
barefoot and tattered cast away like
Gilligan's Island shorts and a dirty
t-shirt and dehydrated and wandering a
desert before days and if that guy is as
qualified for your job as you are you're
a [ __ ] loser of such epic humiliating
proportions I would be ashamed to have
anyone find out that guy took my job he
doesn't speak English what did they do
your job training in pantomime [ __ ]
Oh point point I see point boy you're
out of here guys holy you should have
tried harder nobody [ __ ] about
immigrants taking that job if that
person has skills of any level like a
brain surgeon sitting around the Beverly
Hills hotel lounge you know it really
chaps my ass Barry Scandinavian fellas
are coming over taking all our good
neurosurgery positions
the Norwegians specifically I said we
found ourselves a bottle of Jack Daniels
and go stop us at Ouija ass the first
Ouija we see jump out of that Explorer
pound him
[ __ ] immigrants all started with that
Einstein once they brought him over from
Germany and we didn't have any good
genius jobs who has a trickle-down
effect
Britain is proud to boast the we're home
to the most hard-working diligent and
adaptable workforce in Europe the polls
of course you get a lot of right-wing
people saying all these polls they come
over here taking our jobs
I was thinking four guys from Poland
arrives he doesn't speak the language
doesn't have any money doesn't know
anyone and he takes your job on the
first day your [ __ ] [ __ ] off do you ever
hear people say that about me that the
Mexicans are stealing the jobs people
say that you never heard that you never
heard that lying-ass [ __ ] around
I'm not making that up though right I'm
not first of all that's the stupidest
thing I ever heard in my life how the
[ __ ] do you steal a job I've never seen
a Mexican walk into a restaurant
give me the dishes that [ __ ] never
happened on my foot
no no we don't want the money we rubber
gloves on your luck
don't touch my Palmolive so stupid if
you're gonna steal a job why don't you
steal a great job like who was decided
to steal these [ __ ] jobs that's what
I wanna are you ready to steal some jobs
today yeah minimum wage we can do work I
wish they would steal because I was 40
Mexicans would just raid the Apple store
the Genius Bar is ours
the [ __ ] out of here nerds Mexicans to
run the Apple Store not it's good nerds
walking what are you mixing steel about
silly max if we can sell oranges we can
sell up okay got that fun I've never
asked you this before and we've been
good friends for many years okay I made
that up but we have no no we're friends
we're good friends but I don't know what
you're I'm McDonald is that Irish is
that Scottish what's your ethnic
background is polish realize that Donald
you know well I live my parents changed
their names they had to because of the
constant ribbing they'd get for being
polish you know and so they changed the
name to McDonald but you know it's one
of the things that you go you know I
mean I get a little upset about it you
know because you know you're always
jokes yeah you can't make jokes about
other people but for some reason you
make jokes about Polish people you know
I'll like it all right
I shouldn't that sounds bad yeah I mean
I had an experience you know I go in and
I order a Polish sausage you know from
this guy you know and so the guy says to
me Oh
oh you must be Polish and I said come on
man I mean come on think about it what
you're saying you know I'm trying to
okay I knock some sense into this
fellow's head maybe give him a a wider
world view yeah did you think because I
order a Polish sausage I'm polish I said
what if somebody came in here and
ordered french toast with you would you
think he was French you know right yeah
what if somebody came in here in order
to why a Belgian waffle
would you consider that guy a Belgian
you know I mean I mean I mean if a guy
came in in order to German bratwurst
would you would you consider that fellow
to be a a German fella potato salad I
suppose you think he was German - yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
Wow you talk to this guy for a while
[Applause]
with racist you have to get three times
really get it into their head right I
said the guy came in he ordered a Cuban
hamburger are you gonna see he's a Cuban
right right right I said I think it is
absolutely ridiculous that just because
I community or dur a Polish sausage why
would you jump to the fact that I'm
polish right and the guy says to me well
first of all it's a hardware store so
anyways this is the Monday morning
podcast everybody if you're new to it
welcome if you're from another country
you stay put you stay you stay right
where you are we don't need you anymore
all right we're doing just fine with the
immigrants that we're abusing over here
right now you sit the [ __ ] down I don't
even know what's going on there's some
sort of immigration thing going on in
the news and everybody's [ __ ]
flapping their arms right and the guys
and the red ties are going I'm the [ __ ]
out of here and the guys and the blue
ties are like right same old [ __ ]
[ __ ] I love when they go like well the
immigrants you know they do the jobs
that Americans don't want to do I love
how that they always put it back on like
they always get it off the rich guys
like immigrants do the jobs Americans
don't want to do that's that's such a
[ __ ] brilliant way of saying that
Americans don't want to be grossly
underpaid for back baked breaking work
that makes somebody else's zillion
[ __ ] dollars do you think those
immigrants want to do those jobs and I
love when they sit there and go oh this
they're happy the [ __ ] happy bent
over at the waist all day picking jelly
beans huh you want to [ __ ] do that
out in Candyland fields I don't think
anybody wants to they're basically
saying we can't get away with sweatshop
labor in this country
more because of unions alright and then
they but they spin it around they got
the Americans don't want to do this job
you telling me you couldn't find an
American to go out and go pick some
[ __ ] apples if you pay them right huh
who the [ __ ] wouldn't want to go out go
pick some apples you get that bag right
you're walking around out and [ __ ]
there nobody breathing down your neck
you just up there picking apples like
Johnny Appleseed I'd love to be a
[ __ ] Apple picker if you paid me you
know you want to give me 30 cents a
[ __ ] month to go pick apples yeah go
[ __ ] yourself you picked the [ __ ]
apples you'll see that they don't want
to work there they'll have a work ethic
he's Christian anyways gotta go find
some guy that used to sleep on a rock
under a [ __ ] waterfall to do that
goddamn job course she did
some guy walked here you know from
Zimbabwe grab myself a piece of [ __ ]
oak or whatever some like peat pine or
some [ __ ] right doggie paddled his whole
[ __ ] way over here yeah you think
he's scared of picking some apples for
no money doesn't give a [ __ ] he's happy
to be back on the land but you got to go
to that [ __ ] guy that level of
struggle in life to find somebody to go
out to go you know roll the cantaloupes
in after the [ __ ] harvest right why
because we don't want to do it because
we won't [ __ ] work for a dollar a
month you rich [ __ ] oh I'm on a [ __ ]
tear this morning unbelievable
[Music]
but when a willing victim Lewis
committed now to inherit his pills and
the greatest and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]